[Music]
hello and welcome once again
to i'd like to know our question and
answer bible program
and we thank you for joining us my name
is c.a murray
i'm in the company of pastor stephen
bohr the president and
speaker here at secrets unsealed thank
you for being part of this ministry
thank you for what you do to support
this ministry
and thank you for sending in your
questions we have gotten
uh pastor tells me an impressive list of
questions
and we thank you for that because we
could not do what we are called to do
unless we get your assistance and your
questions so thank you
should you want to join in and if you
may have a question we ask you to write
to
tv at some tv.org
tv at some tv dot o r g
and as the lord gives us strength we
will answer your questions
from the word of god we are convicted
and convinced
that you don't need to hear man's
thinking or the mind of man you need to
hear a word from the lord
and whenever we get a question that's
what we attempt to do give you a word
from the lord
so we thank you and we encourage you to
send in your questions and we will get
to them
as many as we can during each program we
want to start by having a word of prayer
so i will pray
and then we will launch out we've got a
impressive stack of questions a couple
left over from
last program and a brand new stack that
the pastor has uh
shared with me so we've got a lot to do
in the next less than 30 minutes now
join me if you will
as we pray father god we praise you we
thank you
for being a wonderful god we are
thankful that your word
can be understood and that spiritual
things are spiritually discerned
so we ask now for the mind of christ the
spirit of christ to
enlighten and illuminate our minds and
our hearts as we dig into your word give
us
information give us inspiration give us
encouragement as we seek to know your
will
and to do your will and we thank you in
jesus name
amen and amen you know i love
leftovers
[Laughter]
so the first question is the leftover
from last week
and that's a question that comes up
quite frequently
and it says like this lucifer
was created by god god created
everything
how come god didn't prevent sin
from coming into this world um
so that's the question you know there is
a very interesting statement i cannot
give you chapter and verse
where ellen white says this pastor
sin is an entity a reality for which no
explanation can be given
if we could explain it perhaps we could
excuse it
like like a a note to the teacher from
your parents you know the dog ate my
homework or
some other kind of thing but there is no
explanation for it
it's it's a reality that has no
explanation it has no right to exist
but it does exist and it did not catch
god by surprise
but uh you know it when you read um
uh the spirit of prophecy you get a very
clear understanding that
that there was war in heaven there was
disagreement in heaven
something started in satan's heart that
had to do
with jealousy had to do with an
exaltation of self we see that in
isaiah and we see that in ezekiel also
but no explanation can be given her i
cannot give you reason
why it is there it started it spread it
infected one third of the heavenly host
and we are dealing with the consequences
the tentacles of it even to this day
but praise god it will not go on forever
uh very good points a couple of other
things
is that god
is a god that respects freedom of choice
yes
if god had surrounded himself only with
creatures who could say yes to him
there would be no freedom of choice and
so
uh the fact that god was willing to
create lucifer
even though he knew that lucifer was
going to sin in heaven yes
the fact that god created adam and eve
even though he knew
that adam and eve were going to choose
to sin
shows how much god respects
freedom of choice well said because
without freedom of choice there's no
love
because love demands choosing the person
you're going to love
yes and so some people say well you know
but why
didn't god simply decide not to create
lucifer
well that's a very good question and
you know nobody would ever know that god
had thought to himself well you know if
i create lucifer he's going to go
against me so i better spare myself all
the
problems you know that would be a
problem with the character of god
because god would be saying you know if
i create a creature
that says no to me it's going to cause
me problems
yes so i'm just going to create beings
that can say yes
yes no freedom of choice right right no
love yeah
the second point is we usually think of
the consequences of sin
as hurting us but
did god already know the agony and the
pain
that sin was going to cause to him yes
he knew he knows the end from the
beginning he knew he was going to have
to give up his only begotten son
he knew that his son would be beaten
upon
that his son would sweat drops of blood
in gethsemane he knew
that his son would be hung on a cross
and that he would cry out my god my god
why have you forsaken me
so why didn't god spare himself yes
the pain and suffering caused by sin he
could have said no
i i if i created him and eve i know
whenever you send my son
so i'm going to spare myself the problem
we usually think about what it would
cost
us very true but we don't think about
what it would cost god and we usually
don't think about
the issue of freedom of choice you know
god has to live with himself
yes and so when god he knows that
lucifer is going to sin and adam and eve
are going to sin he decides to create
them anyway yeah your second point was
the one that occurred to me first the
fact that
we think of the suffering engendered by
us during these years
but what about the suffering that god
has gone through i remember talking with
a person
uh in a department store so i don't know
how he got on a subject
and he he was saying you know if god was
really god then people wouldn't suffer
and there wouldn't be any pain
um you know someone in his family had
died
and i was trying to tell him uh how
could god do otherwise
god you know god cannot say okay
boer gets to live murray has to die uh
boer is my friend murray is my enemy
we make that choice and god respects our
choice you know
he cannot do otherwise uh to be fair to
be
just remember that this this world is a
lesson book for the universe people are
looking on
this will ultimately be explained and uh
it will be seen
that god is just god is fair god did not
coerce
god did not force that those are satan's
tools they're not god's
um he's got to be fair so even though he
he he opened himself up for seven
thousand years of suffering
he chose to do that because of you know
it's like
and i'll end with this when parents
decide to have
children you don't know what that child
is going to turn out to be
now you've got a wonderful son he's
talented he works here at the ministry
you've got a wonderful daughter who is a
uh in management uh at an establishment
good kids turned out well but you didn't
know that right you took a chance
you chose to have children anyway you
prayed
you had you trained you followed the
biblical counsel as best you could
but you had no guarantee that they were
going to turn out
well well they did praise the lord well
uh
god knew what was going to happen
but that's the way love is man love
cannot pull it
pull its reins in it cannot close in on
itself god so loved that he gave god so
loved that he created
even though it was going to cause him
pain he loved enough
uh to create and to to suffer with us
through all of this given the fact that
it's not going to last forever
one day it's all going to be over i
think that's a marvelous thing it cost
him more than it costs us
well said but we usually think about us
you know
our pain our suffering our sorrow look
at everything that's happening because
adam and eve sinned because god created
them
but we don't think that the pain and the
anguish
that god feels as a result of sin
yes okay here's another one
you know we just had our anchor school
of theology
recently and we studied revelation 15
through revelation chapter 22
and uh we dealt with the sixth and
seventh plagues
for quite an extended period of time
indeed you did and
actually number five six and seven and
uh
basically just to summarize uh we notice
that the fifth flag is a plague of
darkness
the sixth flag is the drying up of the
preparing the way for the drying up of
the euphrates
and the seventh plague of course is the
second coming of christ
and this question is this i would be
grateful to hear your thoughts on
revelation 17 verse 16.
so if you could read that verse and then
the question is after you read the verse
is this to occur at the sixth plague in
other words does revelation 17 verse 16
occur at the moment of the sixth plague
okay
revelation chapter 17 and verse 16.
and i'm reading from the new king james
and the ten horns
which you saw on the beast these will
hate
uh the harlot make her desolate and
naked
eat her flesh and burn her with fire
and that the only do you want 17 also 17
yeah 17 too for god has put it into
their hearts to fulfill his purpose to
be of one mind
and to give their kingdom to the beast
until the words of god are fulfilled
okay now this is referring to the harlot
um and when you notice at the beginning
of chapter 17
the harlot fornicates with the kings of
the earth yes
of course this is symbolic language it's
not a literal harlot
uh fornicating literally with the kings
of the earth
it simply means that this is an apostate
church
that has illicit re political
relationships
with the political rulers of the world
key being political relationships
in other words yes the church uniting
with the state precisely
which which is uh fornication according
to the bible yes
so for a period of time this harlot has
her way
she sits on the waters of the euphrates
the euphrates represents multitudes
nations tongues and peoples and her name
is babylon babel ancient babylon sat
upon the river euphrates yes and she has
daughters that do her bidding
chapter 17 says that everything goes
well for her
for a period of time for a period of
time but then at the moment of the fifth
plague darkness falls upon the throne of
the beast which is
another way of speaking of the harlot
and when
darkness falls upon the upon the throne
of the beast and the kingdom
of this beast or of the highland it's
filled with darkness
then the kings of the earth and the
multitudes the wad represented by the
waters
are going to say now wait a minute yes
this harlot has deceived us those waters
will dry
into thinking that those people that are
persecuted are on the wrong side
and were on the right side but now we
notice that darkness is on our side
and light is on their side so what's
going to happen is the kings
as well as the people that they govern
over are going to
dry up on the harlot yes in other words
they're going to turn
against the harlot and there's where you
have revelation chapter 17 verse 16
fulfilled
so you have the darkness of the fifth
plague that awakens
the kings of the earth to see that the
harlot has deceived them
they withdraw their support and then
they avalanche themselves
upon the harlot and her daughters to
destroy them
and then of course you have the seventh
plague which is the second coming of
christ yes
so that's exactly where revelation 17
verse 16 fits
within the context of the book of
revelation
the deception you know in
the broadest context will not last
forever
but they will realize they have been
deceived and turn against the deceiver
and the deceiving entity so well said
and they will
you know the whole world basically is
going to ally
itself against a small remnant of god
yes
they were told in revelation that they
worship only god
they worship on his holy sabbath they
keep the commandments of god
and practically the entire world is
going to be allied against them
yes but jesus will intervene he will
come on the battlefield
and the small remnant will be delivered
excellent excellent there is a word that
you use i'm going to have to call it a
bore-ism because i've never heard it
used by any other preacher any place
else
and it caught me during the uh during
the anchors you use the term
avalanche themselves that's that's a
boarism that's a brand new word
unless you've added to the lexicon
i really like it you mean to throw
yourself on
a guru yeah avalanche themselves i've
never heard that before
well i'm kind of a weird guy but i love
it i don't think that's going to be
added to the dictionary anytime soon
but that's all right uh so anyway i hope
that that uh helps answer that question
uh now we have another question based on
first thessalonians
4 and verse 14. so maybe if you could
look up that verse
and then i want to say something about
the person who is asking this question
uh so first thessalonians chapter 4 and
verse 14
14. for if we believe that jesus died
and rose again
even so god will bring with him those
who sleep in jesus okay so as
the as the idea goes among some churches
uh it says there at the end of the verse
that god will bring
with him from heaven to earth
those who sleep in jesus so if he's
going to bring
those who slept in jesus it must means
that he that he has
taken them at some point before yes so
the idea is he raptured them to heaven
seven years before the glory is coming
and then he brings them back with him to
the earth
so that is the idea behind this question
and let me just say something about this
individual that questions
uh he sends us a plethora of questions
um and unfortunately most of the
questions have the intention
of saying i gotcha in other words this
program is primarily for questions of
people who are sincere
that are really searching to say you
know i don't quite understand this in
the bible
but this person asks questions by by
saying you know you're wrong about this
you're wrong about that and then he
asked the question
well he's already answered his own
questions yes so
you know we we love receiving questions
here but we want the questions
not to to have the purpose of
contradicting but the purpose of
clarifying
and explaining things that are not clear
in the minds of people
that are contacting us yes so i wanted
to make that very clear but this is
the question presumably see that begins
with presumably
your recently expanded 18 series
misunderstood text about the state of
the dead
was meant to cover all of the
at least major misunderstood texts on
this issue
however i did not see unless i missed it
that you covered the commonly cited text
of first thessalonians 4 verse 14.
i myself have not found your prior
explanatory claim
for this that god will bring the
resurrected saved
with jesus from earth to heaven to be
exegetically
founded or correct nor actually
topically related to or explained
by the spirit of prophecy passage that
you cite
is there a reason why you did not
discuss that passage at all
in this series so i need to answer that
we did not deal with this particular
question
in the series on the state of the dead
because i had already dealt with it
elsewhere
in fact if you would like to really get
the
what i have on that particular verse in
the study notes
prophetic panorama pages 78 to 84
i do a meticulous study of that verse
and basically the point that i try to
show
from that verse is that when it says
here
for if we believe that jesus died and
rose again
even so god will bring with him
those who sleep in jesus
there are two persons mentioned here it
is
god and jesus yes god will bring
with jesus those who slept in jesus
so the question is does god the father
come down and bring with jesus
those who died and resurrected
or does god pick up
uh actually send jesus and then brings
jesus back to heaven where the father is
and my point is
that really the father sends jesus
there's no evidence that the father is
going to come at the second coming
the father sends jesus correct and then
the father is in heaven and he brings
jesus
back to heaven with the lord who sleeps
those who sleep in jesus
christ and the succeeding verses make
that very clear yes says jesus arrives
upon the earth
and that the dead in christ rise and
they're caught up in the cloud to ascend
to heaven well
if they're going to heaven when jesus
comes they didn't go to heaven before
precisely keep reading see that's the
thing don't stop there
don't put a period there's 15 16 17 keep
on reading
and it kind of works itself out and
explains itself
yeah you get a context for for those who
are asleep in jesus
those who are not asleep in jesus those
who died in sin
those who died saved so you got to keep
reading you can't just stop there and i
love your explanation well done
god who is in heaven the father will
bring to heaven right
jesus along with those who died in jesus
and by the way this is kind of uh kind
of the same thing that happened at the
ascension of christ
yes the father sent angels
they caught up jesus in the cloud and
then they took jesus
and so at the second coming the same
thing is going to happen
jesus is going to come with the angels
the righteous will be caught up in the
clouds excellent and then the father
will bring
them yes to the father's house excellent
so i believe that that is exegetically
very sustainable
according to the text in its context and
its context very very true
very very good so oh by the way there is
a bible translation
the contemporary english version that
translate that's that verse this way
we believe it that jesus died and was
raised to life
we also believe that when god brings
jesus back again
he will bring with him all who had faith
in jesus before they died love it love
it i just i never read that
translation beautiful translation well
said so this is not a borism
[Laughter]
no that's from the word okay
uh we have about seven minutes left let
me just go through this very quickly
this is a long one
and i've talked enough so i'm gonna i'm
gonna throw this one at you ah here we
go
i have actually attended the church of
god seventh day
and other sabbatarian churches it was
then
when it was when i studied the writings
of the early church bishops
that i realized what is and is not
christianity
sabbatarianism is not christianity
the church did not assemble on one day
but
three days the first the fourth and the
sixth
the church did not assemble on the
sabbath day
early christians observed observed the
when they were in the land of israel
however they did not observe the sabbath
day
outside of israel the sabbath day was
revealed by god
to israel alone and then he puts
then he puts in parentheses see jubilees
and the previous popes well
jubilees is not part of the bible the
sabbath law is for the land of israel
not for the entire world and then he
gives four examples here
uh that come from not from the bible not
from the new testament
but comes from what is known as the
teaching
uh of the apostles that has the date of
about 100
a.d when all the apostles had already
passed away
so how do we deal with this claim
that uh the church did not assemble on
the sabbath day
and that the sabbath was only for israel
what pops into my mind
very quickly well two things one um
acts 13 42 uh 42-44
where we see meetings on on the sabbath
now of course paul's methodology of
evangelism was to begin in the synagogue
he would go to the synagogue
and then branch out from there we see
this methodology in galatians we also
sit here in the book of acts
verse 42 so when the jews went out of
the synagogue the gentiles
begged that these words might be
preaching them the next sabbath
so these are gentiles these are non-jews
right so this is
a sabbath meeting now when the
congregation had broken up
and many jews and devout prosecutes
followed paul and barnabas
speaking to them persuading them to
continue in the grace
on the next sabbath almost the whole
city
came together to hear the words of god
but when the jews saw the multitudes
they were filled with enemy of course
they were there were
some jealousy there but we see paul's
method of working
uh uh with the broader community he he
said i'm i'm a
i'm an evangelist to the gentiles but
there was a methodology to what he did
now
a second thing that pops in my mind very
quickly is mark 2 27-28
right the sabbath was made for man
mankind
not man for the sabbath so the sabbath
existed as something
constructed for mankind's benefit not
jews
uh the first sabbath was instituted long
before the first jew
appeared so we cannot uh
biblically defend that it was just a
jewish institution the third thing i
would say is
if the sabbath is only for jews then the
ten commandments are only for jews good
point
because the ten commandments the sabbath
is one of the ten commandments that
means
loyalty to your wife obeying your
parents not stealing
not killing not none of that is any good
anymore either you take them all
or you take them none you can't take one
you like and leave one you don't like
they are taken as a group all ten of the
commandments
are the word of god you know i heard
some a christian once told me he says
well you know all of the commandments
were nailed to the cross and then
jesus unnailed nine of them
and of course of course joe cruz had a
good answer for that the
evangelist joe cruz yes he said that
would be like
cutting off uh your ten fingers and then
sewing
nine of them back on yeah
you know the arguments that come up are
so absurd they are
many times against the sabbath i can't
understand the reason why people
uh would say oh no the sabbath that's a
yoke of bondage you know we don't have
to keep the sabbath
i mean i love the sabbath it's a whole
24 hours
where i can suspend everything i do
during the week
everything that distracts me from
focusing on the lord
you know 24 whole hours that i can spend
with my beloved jesus
and with nothing else yes so so what's
the problem
you know to develop a love relationship
it takes time
it does indeed so if if the sabbath was
kept
we would always remember the creator yes
we would always remember the redeemer
and we would always remember that in the
kingdom come
we're going to go from sabbath to
sabbath to worship before the lord yes
if you reject the sabbath as bondage you
don't really
understand the sabbath and you don't
understand the lord of the sabbath
anybody who has a wife or has someone
they love
knows that that relationship is enriched
as you spend time together you spend
time with your wife you're leaving in a
couple days
you're gonna be traveling with your wife
you're gonna have a nice time together
because you love her
right so it's not a burden to spend time
with aurora because
you you love each other so it's not a
burden to spend time with the lord uh
because we love him and and the the
ensign of our love
is our willingness to spend time with
him yeah and you know
we work four days a week here we work
monday tuesday wednesday and thursday
which means that we have friday sabbath
and sunday off yes i'll tell you i
delight in those three days
amen because i can be home with my wife
during the week i'm working
you know i have things that i'm doing i
arrive late in the afternoon we kind of
have supper
there's a lot of distractions yes but
those three days
yeah we have just for ourselves together
praise the lord and uh so
you know when when a young man is
courting a young woman
you know he doesn't say when he has to
take her out to some
concert or something and say oh no yeah
i have to spend a whole two hours with
her at the concert
how boring no he'd rather the concert
last
four hours yes instead of two hours yes
because of love
yes and so you know for people to say
that the sabbath is a yoke of bondage
that it was for the jews
and that we don't need to take time for
the lord it just doesn't make
any sense yeah and you know people who
keep sunday they don't actually keep
sunday that's right you know they go to
church for
two two and a half hours three hours
maybe yeah and then they go out to eat
in a restaurant or they watch the
football game or they go out to
you know play ball whatever that's not
you know it's like you do every day
right with with the three hours of
religious stuff in between
yes yes yes so anyway well i hope that
you know our time is just about up i
hope that uh
our answers have been satisfactory based
on holy scripture
we want to thank you once again for your
willingness to send us your questions
we covet those questions and we do the
research and we try to answer them
in harmony with the word of god thank
you so much for being with us
and for seeing for myself god bless you
god keep you in his care and we hope to
see you
next time on our program i'd like to
know
[Music]
you